nearly one in five couple
say money is their greatest relationship
challenge and more than half disagree on
how much savings they'll actually need
to reach their retirement goals so with
so many couples getting married this
year after a long year of pandemic
proposals and postponed weddings
fidelity investments has a reminder to
start forever on the right financial
footing
and yet according to fidelity's 2021
couples and money study
while 57 percent of couples claim their
joint retirement decision makers more
than half disagree on how much is needed
as we said to reach those goals their
findings also reveal that women
need to get more involved one in five
women
still report having little to no
involvement in retirement planning
so our message is it's okay to delegate
but don't abdicate staying involved in
financial decisions
really helps both partners to feel
confident about the future
she says bottom line make money a team
sport she says if you need to make a
weekly
financial date night yeah to discuss
your finances and communicate
openly start saving as early as possible
for those newlyweds
she says if you're looking for tips and
tools to help you navigate a whole host
of life events
you can go to fidelity.com forward slash
couples